[Music]
I
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at lwith cry.com
mugclub for $89 annually join the fight
at lwith cr.com mugclub
[Music]
today
don't
St that's what I
[Music]
know
oh that was a good one glad to be with
you the long sip good night yes hey hey
the speakers are off right there you
these headphones by the way these
headphones are so money but the problem
is it's like one of those GI Jo's that
has the extra joints you know what I
mean so it's like they can go up but
then also
fold them down you're just you're to
just there's too many of the joints look
I can fold them this way so I every time
now before the show I I just go bum now
this I got to think yeah they're me
meant to fold up and transport which is
pretty terrible great they're great
headphones in
Disguise which actually that's a perfect
lead into the Photoshop rundown we'll be
talking about the trans day of
remembrance today debunking the idea
because the trans day of remembrance is
predicated on the idea that trans people
are being murdered in record numbers
record uh here across the United States
and I know what you're thinking hold on
a second you're late no no that was
trans remembrance week yes it was week
of remembrance not to be confused with
transvisibility day not in March not to
be confused with trans visibility week
not to be confused with trans awareness
day yes so we're going to talk about
that uh Argentina just elected a new a
new leader he's super based super based
super rightwing I don't think it ends
well but it never does for South
American countries that being said we're
going to explain this to you and
something else I really wanted to get
into the January 6th tapes that were
released um we appreciate that they were
but I also you know comment below I I do
wonder where were you where was
everybody else because we were covering
this immediately when it happened I
understand there are new angles I
understand there's some new footage but
the idea that people being escorted
peacefully into the capital or that
security camera footage that this is
it's not new it's that a lot of people
were banned if they covered it on big
Tech and so a lot of people both on the
left and the right said well we don't
want to be banned we were covering it
that year that month we will show you
what we had back then versus what's
developed there have been a couple of
developments namely as far as
criminality involving the police offic
but we'll do a little bit of then and
now because you have been lied to for a
very long period of time we're also
doing a big truck giveaway at crter
shop.com which we will uh discuss and
more and I still have to adjust my
headon the speakers are off though right
I'm getting a little bit of an echo all
right CEO number two Captain Morgan how
are you sir I'm doing well how are you
good yeah yeah I'm good your headphone
Fiasco over no they're great headphones
it's just I'm not used it's a different
sound you know mean when it's a
different sound you're what little B
throws you off little bit Yeah throws
you off yeah it happens yeah I get
thrown off you get thrown off yeah
that's the that's the early onset
dementia no I'm not that old oh that's
right show them your hands show them
your hands steady have you ever seen him
shake that much it's like Nick Noti
Warrior all right in third chair when
you hear this you know him you love them
you can follow him at joshin on the
Instagram on the gram as the kids call
it fresh in from Tulsa how are you Josh
good good I'm I'm good yeah just wasn't
Tulsa last night yeah was a fun fun time
yeah it was good I'm excited for
Thanksgiving yeah that means he has
nothing good to say that means he has
nothing to say about Tulsa tuls Tulsa's
fine let's talk Thanksgiving talk about
Halloween was Rec why are you so excited
for Thanksgiving man I love to eat oh
okay I love I love a good turkey dinner
and mashed potatoes and yeah your dad
brought in candy today by the way really
yeah he brought in Halloween candy he
bring it in his van yeah did you guys
ever
do well I had to meet him in the van for
the candy did you ever do like family
costumes like dress up as a family for
Halloween uh we did like one time I was
the Octo mom and I just had everyone in
one big tarp a that's cute this year my
my my daughter and I we went as Woody
Allen and his wife wow that's
horrible this is what happens when you
don't set up when you don't pre-write
everything like uh what was it remember
nor McDonald talks about Comics
Unleashed with what's his name what's
that guy's name uh Byron Byron Allen
Byron Allen yeah and you know you
couldn't be more leashed right they go
through everything after the tap it and
they they cut it down and he would try
and set up people like he would turn to
John Lit and say uh John I hear you're
getting
older oh
Unleashed he's out the dogghouse man let
him go well good I am looking forward to
Thanksgiving too I don't know if you
guys have some Thanksgiving plans we
will not be doing shows Wednesday
through Friday because uh no one here
wants to work all right sorry I don't
that so much it's because of trans
membrance just trying to keep a
motorcycle I celebrate the week after
that's Theo those are the high holy days
hands Rememberance Day gosh if you
listen faintly you can hear the sound of
TAPS being played in the distance for
all 36 26 who have 26 who have lost
their
lives there's so much there that's just
a lie and it's just it's a lie that's
agreed upon okay before any of that I
know you don't like this person neither
do I but cardi B now just uh these
moments are few and far between where
you see these celebrities you know they
seem to be getting red pilled for a
moment you can't always depend on that
red pill and I wouldn't be surprised to
see cardi B go back because it's often
just based on selfish motivations they
don't actually look at the big picture
however this is progress baby steps baby
elephant steps she's complaining about
uh leftist policies specifically that
have ruined a place she once loved New
York don't ask me I don't give a the
resume that they send I don't give a I'm
not endorsing no presidents no more cuz
how is that a 100100 million budget cut
in New York C City for for
um schools Library uh police safety and
look talking about yeah we Wars we could
fun to Wars about we don't got it but we
got it like we're the greatest nation no
the we're not we're going through some
right now like say it say it we really
going through we we really really really
really really really really really are
right now I don't know if they should
say
that from California I know people from
Atlanta so we always be like I always be
like yeah New York is the greatest place
the world yeah like New York is dirty
and it is dirty and we're going to get
even dirtier with the budget cut and
yeah we talking about we we could fund
two Wars that's like trying to front
like yeah I got the money to support to
but you really don't they don't want to
say the word but we're going through a
recession right now we really really
really on okay really really really
really yeah she gave me a lot of facts
there she like a photo she's like a
photo negative of a lint chocolate
Chef I am the Amica the chocolate like
it just I really really is that it does
does that serve any practical purpose
like I understand like an actual shower
cap but that's like loose it has like a
band and it looks like a chef it's like
rat tattoo let me pretend like I know
what I'm talking about I think it's it's
to give it some air and oxidize the uh
up in her hat just some small Jewish
record executive like R
telling I like how she's complaining
about how New York's not the same as it
used to be it's not in its Glory she's
like yeah back in my day we would just
drug men and and Rob them in their sleep
back in the day when it was classy when
it was filled with people like me it was
really really really classy yeah she
didn't do any of those you got to trim
your nails when you click there you go
that's what she looks like but hey you
know what uh better late than than never
I guess a day late and a dollar short
but progress you know you saw this with
Nicki Minaj a little bit then she kind
of disappeared uh and you see this now
with her and then I bet you she'll pull
she'll pull back back a little bit let's
see I I'm still waiting for the person
who becomes redpilled and stays that way
now I don't mean people like James Woods
who were always pretty pretty aware you
know people like that who are always
very politically astute I mean someone
who was left not paying attention then
wakes up and stays that way you know you
can comment below maybe I'm missing
something maybe I'm missing somebody
there might be some people but there
aren't many so I hope she stays on this
path I mean we've been talking about
this for years you've known about it for
years obviously New Yorkers have known
about it for years as seen by the net uh
decrease in population which is really
hard to do in a large city like that uh
I I I hope she continues this I think so
but focus on something other than the
city being dirty I I'm glad you came
over but I need you to focus on the
economy a little bit more it's like yes
I have a dirty City but I'm I'm broke
and on the streets so maybe we okay
that's why I said like we don't have
money for two Wars listen open your ears
stupid I think it was more about she
said dummy you're so dumb drowning in
rats that's not the biggest problem it
is a problem if you're a problem it's a
problem if you're the biggest the guy
drowning in rats you can't save all the
starfish you can save that one starfish
in her Brown starfish that's the whole
city oh boy she needs to clean up the
City by first getting a bucket and a mop
yes yes because only you can prevent
cities like New York and by the way
she's the filthiest person I've ever I
know oh she's got the W yeah exactly is
it just are you talking about your
apartment
yeah remember she was like you got to
trim your nails when you clean your
by the way if you ever at some
point see this the YouTube dump
button just heading over to rumble yeah
a whole video sh like you got to trim
your nails you got to trim your nails
when you clean your cuz you go
in you cut your like ah you ever recoil
physically it's like when I was watching
Dark Knight in the close-ups of Maggie
Gyllenhaal like oh God that scared me oh
Jesus she's the girl she's awful Harvey
Dent you didn't even give him a tough
choice all right jeez Batman that that
makeup's really covering your
eyesight wait I thought it was Jake oh
God okay
so I don't know is that guy that where
is she it's
me tell enough of your tricks
Joker that's you're hideous it's me I
swear swear to me she strapped at the
bombs and he's like I got to
chw no definitely D I got to I think
there's a bat signal or something got to
go really come and save me
Batman it's hard to believe you're all
from the same
family you're more of a character
actress you know your brother's
The Joker yes you're like the paulam of
female actresses you're probably very
talented but I don't want to see you on
the P all right they look alike they
have the same
mustache okay all right all right okay
we get it we P cleans okay I apologize
no no I'm the one who started it and I
apologize to the Maggie Gyllenhaal fans
she is a good actor she is a good she is
actress how do you think she's been
around so
long
so she has to Argentina all right they
elected a Libertarian candidate and I
say this because I know that there are
differences politically between
different countries they mean different
things I what you would even consider uh
very libertarian uh this person uh have
you now is it is it Malay or melee me it
is M okay I thought it was melee and
then you corrected
me I didn't correct just not
Maggie no
le please no
le
okay all right so
melee bet you can't elect just one is
going to be the new president of
Argentina Argentina elected the
right-wing libertarian Javier M as its
new president on Sunday voters rolled
the dice on an outsider with radical
views to fix an economy battered by
runaway inflation giving melay an
economist and former TV pundit a clear
win with 56% of the ballots and nice I
know you usually don't elect a a Charles
Dickens character you don't but in
this
Argentina I love this guy dudo he's
hilarious he is hilarious okay he wanted
to be my president well I now get into
how this probably goes to be clear P
wasn't all wrong and we'll do a segment
on that but you know look you have to
understand the socialist government
right Chile and people were saying the
great Chilean success story back then
when pay was there now I get it that
these awful socialists they would always
have these coups they would have
gorillas this is what happens in South
America because they have the kind of
Constitution that we do that being said
pishe improved the economy a few people
got thrown some from some helicopters
that happens you do there's still a lot
of people who like him there because of
the kind of choice that they have the
pendulum swings back and forth and we'll
get into why the pendulum has has now in
in Argentina swung so far right
certainly for that country first off uh
president Donald Trump issued a
congratulations to melee
saying congratulations to have your
melee on a great race for president of
Argentina the whole world was watching
I'm very proud of you like my
son I wish you were my son oh
no you will turn your country around and
truly make Argentina great again at at
soccer yes I don't know if they're good
at soccer I know Miss Universe they no
one can touch them that's true they're
perfect they won the World Cup I think I
don't know they're they are like the
MVPs of Miss Universe or Miss World with
whatever it is many many years yeah not
mister and our Miss Universe tastes
great on a
cracker
uh just saying it's like Melee twist so
so uh melee describes himself as an
anarcho capitalist and uh he's an
Eclectic so to give you a little and I
love this for example he lives with five
English Mastiffs four of them are clones
of the
original what it was a great dog it was
a great dog I thought about doing that
with hopper and you know what then now
I'll never do it because I wouldn't have
ended up with Joe Lewis but I understand
it if you love a dog if you have the
money you can rock those sideburns make
it happen he former rock band lead
singer I guess that's a real thing yeah
yeah you can clone your animals this
happened oh yeah what yeah he lives with
four clones it's like multiplicity with
English M attack of the Clones that's
awesome I God I hope not those are big
dogs uh he was a former professional
soccer goalkeeper I didn't know that
yeah former tantric sex coach more
impressive and he's converting to
Judaism which I was like is he marrying
a j he's just doing it I think he's just
the ultimate troll okay pretty cool no
one converts to Judaism first off
they're not even asking you to convert
and it's not fun
well and you go from being a tantric sex
coach to converting to judism yes like
it might be limiting yeah hey he's
maturing you go from opening up the hips
to complaining about your hip yeah we're
going to do some uh work down Southway
dig listen don't don't do that with all
the bending and the downward dogging
with the cloning why is it always hot
here it's hot bring in the come on now
come on all right but here's the thing
and we'll get into the numbers as to why
they elected him but Above All Else
melee uh hates yes he reviles leftists
so the reason I say this is because
there can be know we didn't know they
knew they elected him by a large 56% of
the vote yeah that's a pretty big margin
and then when I say this guy hates the
left he's been very open about it and
the public said yeah we want that guy
it's more than anything I wish I hated
anything or loved anything as much as
this guy hates the
left
means exactly what you
think those in audio it's exactly what
you're
picturing he's Sala what is
say
[Laughter]
this by the way for those who listening
to audio that's he's saying like
Ministry you know diversity Equity gone
yeah gender studies gone Public Works
gone gone yeah this is a guy who on air
looking like Ebenezer Scrooge
said if the leftist would rather die
then they better do
it are there no leftist prisons yes are
there no poor houses oh that's right I
close them H hello young boy what day is
it election day you say yes 56% of the
vote I want you to go there into that
window and hang my political dissident
the one is big as me oh remarkable
lad yes kill him now oh here he is melee
uh celebrating the
win look he's taking the proper safety
precaution so it's like no one is at
risk I'm not going like dirty
dancing but I do have to ask before we
get into the policy and today is a silly
day why did he go with the 70s Roman
pansy here as well it's just he's got to
be hot under that
thing he lives in South America it's hot
there yeah Dickens haircut I would not
picture Argentina to be the to do it
okay so looks like a Hogwarts Professor
you know what I don't care like this is
the beauty of it they would tell you
they tell you to get this kind of
haircut and point with your thumb and
then in the States you have Donald Trump
and here you have this guy people say
you know we don't care anymore we don't
care it's sort of like uh you see this
with politics and I think it's a good
thing like you saw with media oh
everything would have to be slick and
professional and you're on a sound stage
and now people say you know we want
people to be accurate but we want some
authenticity I think that's a good thing
you know hey is this guy
qualified maybe maybe not but the truth
you're seeing people saying what we've
been doing is has not been working he's
out Donald trumping Donald Trump he is
which is really hard to is yes very much
so and to the fact that like there's a
lot of things Donald Trump will say I'm
like oh he sounds genuine this guy I
feel like he means everything he says
hat yeah because they're yeah he
said that like why are you calling the
leftist because they are you
tell me what they are stupid it's kind
of like Donald Trump saying because it's
from China's like China that's what the
virus is it's from China where do you
think it's from Argentina they're doing
great melee
M you're just Mr
M so melee was elected of course the
economy right the Argentinian economy is
doing really poor the inflation rate
these this is from Reuters all the
references are available at ler.com have
a few up here uh inflation is
143% in the FED interest rate is 133%
GDP is negative -
2.5% that's that's hard to do I heard
this I listen to NPR all the time so you
don't have to MH thank you and thank you
st this morning when I heard it they're
briefing it said 143% I'm like oh they
must have meant to say 43 yeah or must
meant to say 100 no it's
143% still high and you thought like a
7% you know mortgage rate was really
high talk about an interest rate of
133% yes and how did they get there you
know you can go through the uh the
history sort of the economy in Argentina
so since the 1980s the central bank has
had I guess sort of loose monetary
policy you could say some would say yeah
more pesos and circulation lower rates
to increase borrowing according to the
Harvard International review Argentina
has deeply subsidized Healthcare energy
universities and public transportation
for Citizens all of which the government
can only afford to fund through the
printing of more pesos so they just
printed more
money for social services probably to
stay in power and that crashed the
economy for everybody sounds I mean it's
it's like when here you hear people talk
about social security and it's it's the
the political third rail no one wants to
acknowledge it just just kick that can
down the road for the people to be left
holding the back because you'll be out
of office that's what Argentina's been
doing for a very long time that's what a
lot of these socialist countries have
been doing for a very long time by the
way even countries you see like Denmark
these sort of Nordic models that Bernie
Sanders would point to and they would
say hey hey stop saying we're socialist
we were built on market economies but
they were certainly more left than we
were they had to Veer back to the right
to correct that's the part they never
tell you remember Bernie Sanders
praising Venezuela in chabz remember
Shawn Penn saying that he was a great
hero and he thought it was criminal for
Americans to vilify him you're seeing
the same thing with Argentina if you see
something that seems to be a centralized
economy doing well you see the left
point to it as a success just add time
they did it with Cuba Bernie did it with
the USSR for God's sake he honeymooned
there that was his
sandals and
you should see it in in January yes
exactly very cold and white Venezuela
they did it they did it uh and they've
done it with the Nordic which have had
to change um so here we are so his plan
to fix the economy now it may work it
may not what I'm telling you is he's
been open about this completely abolish
the Argentinian uh Central Bank yeah cut
55% of interior Ministries what you
would probably refer to as like uh
social safety nets you know a lot of
welfare programs cut retirement and
Pension funds AA I I thought it was ABA
no means out okay all right cuz abua is
someone who's like a nanny right Grandma
well you wouldn't throw your yelling for
his abua
ABA the FBI my aba's gonna take care of
CH his grandma's taking up all the jobs
aa
oh is the
ABA this summer the sequel AB in
space leprechaun I guess AB in the hood
AB in the
hood all right so B the Central Bank
there cut 55% of interior Ministries cut
retirement and Pension funds and by the
way be open about it so in other words
the public has said okay we get it this
isn't going to work and he also wants to
to switch to the American dollar yeah
it's a little more stable than the peso
that's a big deal yeah it is a big deal
so right now there's actually a black
market for the dollar and I think the
dollar since 2002 in the last 20 years
up
60,000 mhm in Argentina wow some would
say that's a lot yes it's a good return
yeah golly I don't fully like I'm not an
economist I don't fully understand how
you just go I mean it takes a while like
okay so today we're using pesos and
tomorrow is going to be the dollar well
they outlaw some those things and then
they're like there's a black market
that's why black market exists for it
just allow it to be the the thing and
people will go to it naturally it'll
stabilize your economy a little bit he's
also been pretty uh pretty
straightforward about wanting to
increase relations with and by the way
also wanting to sever some relations
with other countries trading partners I
believe Brazil was one of them he talked
about kind of basically people who are
who are veering more left he's saying
they're not going to keep dragging us
down them uh dragging us down with them
wants to increase uh relations trade
with the United States and specifically
also talks about cutting dependence on
China
we don't make packs with
communist
that guy is I mean again maybe some's
Lost in Translation but he just seems
aggravated with the interview these are
stupid questions I'm not why would I
make any deals with communist Nations
why would I want anything to do with
them this is someone who's seen it lived
it and he's rejecting it and the people
have overwhelmingly rejected it yeah
because their influence there don't
think of the United States where we can
still be a free nation and it's going to
take a lot of time having a communist
influence in a country like that as as
prone to turmoil as South American
countries are can flip you to a
Communist Regime very very very quickly
and he like no look you want to do
business in China in the private sector
fine we're going to align ourselves with
the United States and Israel and be Pro
West Pro Freedom Pro democracy open
markets done they've been seeing it
happen for a while and they have an
election so they have the ability to
change things I think a lot of Latin
American countries are very proud
they're very proud of their culture
they're very proud of their countries
they're very proud of where they come
from and the fact that all of them are
moving out of South America pisses them
off they don't want to have to move
right they want to stay where they want
to stay and that's good for Argentina
they get to the one country there kind
of yeah it'll be interesting to see so
they let's kind of recap this they've
elected a pro United States a small
government president okay this is going
to be a contrast you're going to see
this play out with a lot of other Latin
American leaders for example you can
compare this directly to Brazil where
they decided to go you know my left your
right a little bit uh which policies
will work which policies won't that's
one thing you kind of see by the way
with with Chile just to be clear not
saying that pinese wasn't a fascist but
I think that a lot of people don't
remember what was happening before Pache
I think people aren't remembering what
was happening as far as the economy
there and there's a reason that a lot of
Chileans there are saying yep if we
could have those qualities without the
fascism without the helicopter rides
we'd like to do it because what we have
been doing hasn't worked and you're
seeing this with Argentina so don't let
the left gas light you let's let's let's
keep track of this now my one concern is
they don't have a constitution that's
why it lend itself s to fash to
extremism basically socialist
governments who maybe then don't have
legitimate elections ever again or
fascists who decide to jail political
dissidents it happens a lot more in
South America just like it happened a
lot more in Europe the closest thing
that we have had to a fascist is the
person in office right now don't let the
left fool you and say that it was Donald
Trump name me any political dissidence
Donald Trump has jailed we'll get to
January 6th and uh what's happening with
this Administration right now just to be
clear but that's the closest we have
come compare that to what you've seen
across South America all right we do
know one thing though by the way they're
their top export they're planning on
shifting their economy their top export
um Miss Universe winners is expected to
Skyrocket that is still going to do
great it's just nonstop with Argentina
you got to I think this is actually bad
news news in fact this is Miss Argentina
married Miss Puerto Rico oh that's I
mean you can't take off number one picks
like that that's not yeah
a are they making a movie by
chance you have to go after like the
ugly lesbians that's fine you just can't
take nice pretty women out of the the
pool for the day the men the men they'll
get frustrated come on yeah well maybe
they had a dad who looked like a tale of
two uh mes oh
boy
I couldn't handle two of those guys man
that be that'd be too fun please sir can
I I get I said some more Crossing
chainsaws F so what what do you expect
for their economy okay just to be clear
uh comment below this is something
that's very interesting to watch unfold
in real time and uh you know this of
course nothing exists without you we
going to play hate similar not later on
mug Club bl.com mug Club you can join
you get this show you get the Friday
show you get Alex Jones on Friday you
get Nick depalo every day it's what
supports the entire undercover unit with
the Nashville Manifesto we working on
some other issues there but we are also
by the way right now uh as we go into
the uh the Christmas season holiday
season what really what I mean is
Christmas and Hanukkah that's it well
Thanksgiving we're not there yet almost
there what I really mean is not K Quanza
not yeah for sure celebrated by 1% of
African-Americans and 0% of Africans no
I expect a holiday that was created by a
guy named Ron yeah Ron Everett yeah I'm
Ron my new
I'm run sorry I meant something
something
Kanga check out the Hat all right it's
real yeah ignore my criminal record so
uh we are also doing this though at
crowers shop.com uh for every dollar
that you spend uh you'll is it 10
entries right now I think you're getting
10x entries right now 10 times the
entries for a we're giving away a Ford
Raptor fully loaded Ford Raptor we've
partnered with a new merch company and
that's just from buying any merchandise
as you go into the holiday season so uh
here to actually fill us in uh on this
and uh go out there I guess we have
footage of the Raptor is our very own
Thomas
finigan all right this is a fun one
we're giving away a truck fully loaded
Ford Raptor to walk us through it
finegan give us the skinny here
brother Hi Stephen yeah and you're in a
forest though it seems uh I might need a
little more time uh it turns out they're
nocturnal and I haven't been able to
find one yet you're not H are you
looking for an actual Raptor F
again there was one okay for never mind
you know I'll do it myself Tim cut it
Gerald let's get let's just get we'll go
let's get
[Music]
go we're doing something a little
different uh now at Crowder shop giving
back when you buy something thing you
are entered to win automatically this
brand new Ford Raptor yeah don't forget
the $10,000 in cash money as well on top
of that $10,000 in cash just buy
something at crowers shop.com you'll be
ented to win that money and uh this
fully loaded no no okay yeah Ford Raptor
and
[Music]
money that's a nice truck yeah I like it
got quickly you did yes $10,000 cash in
a truck that's a pretty big deal, yeah
and by the way there's also the promo um
if you go to cred shop.com there's 20%
off hoodies right now use promo code
Patriot 20 uh you get 20% off hoodies as
you go into the holiday season and we
are I know some of you thinking you're
not going to no this isn't yes we're
giving away a truck in $10,000 cash
literally all right do it let's move on
to the transgender Dave remembers the
reason that this matters is because it's
silly it's silly very silly but your
government thinks it's not remember
trans vember
yes remember remember
so just when you thought it was safe to
be heterosexual again because it was
trans Awareness
Week what's month it's trans awareness
month that well the week ended that
weekend so that was the week it was the
week and then the weekend ended but now
today this very day jeez well today I'm
so confused today specifically not to be
confused with trans visibility that's
March 31st yes and trans awareness
something I don't know but today
specifically do you know what day it is
this day this dayus what today was
transgender day of remembrance of course
all new tonight at 11 Monday is
international transgender day of
remebrance it's a day to remember all of
the people
[Music]
who
p
[Music]
I'd say if you see the YouTube dump
button at any point a lot it's all
dumped sure it's all dump right now yeah
whole segment the whole segment well not
almost all of it all right here let me
get back through YouTube really quickly
just for the people who are remaining
there I'll just so if you're watching on
Rumble just humor me a bit hey YouTube
people this whole segment even though
it's true we can't talk about it on
YouTube so head on over to rumble same
thing with January 6 this is why
everyone's a giant
okay encapsulated it perfect now I want
to be clear murder rate for all is five
times higher than that of transgender
individuals it's almost the opposite of
an epidemic so to give you an idea in
202 even the
[Music]
scales
p
[Music]
oh
yo I'm in here I'm in here Gary Gary
what are you doing close the door I uh
um you serious right now yo yo I
[Music]
mean all right so makes sense yeah also
for some context even though the murder
rate is lower than the heterosexual
population here's another truth that is
very important that 48% of all of these
trans individuals killed so basically
half are sex workers
ah a
[Music]
dick
p
[Music]
m
a
[Music]
up
a
[Music]
p
a
[Music]
p
n
[Music]
perpetuate stereotypes and
misinformation The Stereotype that
transgenders are attacked by
sharks fine sharks just are like I'm
sure they canuse them for a seal no they
they confuse them for you know something
they don't like to eat when facts become
stereotypes I know just requesting the
facts how many transer individuals were
killed by shark
[Music]
attacks
oh
[Music]
so let's go to the January 6th tapes
just to be
clear just I don't because we're
probably back on YouTube right now for
like a fraction of a second before we
actually show the January 6ths yeah
actually the good news is they'll allow
us to do it now we had to go back to our
archives to find uh when we immediately
covered this as soon as we were back in
the air in January 6th it happened and
it we had footage clearly showing even
security footage clearly showing people
being peaceful the reason it was hard
for us to find it this morning we were
almost late is because it was removed
from YouTube and we didn't have it in
our archives it was good morning mug
Club we had to go back and search it but
we have it now so let's set this up and
let me ask you this first is there
anything new that has surprised you if
you've been following this or
specifically if you've been watching
this show let us know I'm always kind of
surprised that people are surprised yeah
uh uh of the truth regarding January 6 I
I I wonder where people have been I'm
glad we have access to everything now
but we had access to enough that's why
we did the stream we did the uh the
January 6th live stream and I believe it
was a hurricane Irene I think it was
Irene that was was about to do the
commit is in DC the hurricane is in
Florida right and they canel because of
the Hur they canel it and we ran ours
anyway I think it was a three-hour
stream doing the ins and outs you can go
back and watch that so uh Friday house
Speaker Mike Johnson hey you know what
right now people are happy with him this
is a good move he released thousands of
hours of from what I understand is least
unseen or he announced he he's released
a lot of ours but he's announced he's
going to release thousands and I believe
90 right now is publicly available uh
unseen January 6th footage and I think
we have some clips here speaker Mike
Johnson just announced plans to begin
releasing internal video from the
January 6th Riot there are 44,000 hours
of released first 90 hours will be
posted onto a public Committee website
tonight Johnson says it'll allow
Americans to see what happened on that
day in 2021 okay so he provided some
context uh speaker Johnson said this uh
this releas is to restore America's
trust and faith in their government and
we must have transparency this is
another step towards ke keeping the
promise or promises sorry I made when I
was elected to be your speaker uh the
footage will be made available through
the house committee on the
administration's website we have that
available for you right now you can go
and uh and check that out and uh go
through the archives yourself maybe look
a lot of people think ah I won't go
through this someone else will tell me
what I need to know we've often just
caught things doing this program because
other people don't do it for example we
went through the voting roles in
Michigan and in Nevada like I'm not by
no means are we experts we just realized
that people actually weren't going
through all this because it looks like a
lot to go through so hey if you want to
and send your your uh send your tips to
lwc tips protonmail.com if you spot
something or if you have some
information we'd love to cover it
because we already knew a lot of this to
be clear and hit the like button I guess
to if you plan on maybe watching some of
the footage out there so on January 14th
I believe
20221 we showed you a lot of videos but
I know that we showed you this video
which was released on January 8th of
police holding the doors open to the
capital
[Music]
[Applause]
traitor they're going to lock Us
in disagree with
[Applause]
it come
H so we showed you that on January 14th
2021 you can go back and check out the
episode I didn't want to we don't want
to show ourselves talking about it in
January that would be redundant same day
we also showed you this video from
January 6th of the Capitol Police
removing the barriers for
protesters police are squabbling with
protesters there we
go and they just reached the capital
breached yeah breached yeah breached the
barriers they're one step away from
having those lights on a Tarmac they had
to take the C4 off the gate yes put
their shotguns away because they got to
found an easier breach so on November
18th 2021 the reason I'm showing this to
is
because some of these episodes you can't
find them if you search on YouTube by
the way they were removed uh and a lot
of conservatives were intimidated into
silence back then well we can't cover
January 6th and I know a lot of people
were asking us will you cover January 6
we have several times it's just it's not
available on YouTube go to rumble and of
course mug Club is always the best place
if you can uh that's why we have we're
funded by viewers like you November
18th 2021 we were covering uh Jacob
chancey's sentencing I I say his name is
that the shaman yeah Shaman we showed
you uh this clip that had been released
uh that may of him telling people again
telling people as he was enter to remain
peaceful we showed this in November 2021
everybody Len up
the police here are willing to work with
us and cooperate peacefully like our
first amendment allows gather more
Americans under the condition that they
will come and gather peacefully to
discuss what needs to be done to save
our
country other the other need a show you
understand show
us yeah and then there was the Q on I
don't know if it's in that clip I think
it's like right after you have to remain
peaceful we all had a go laugh about it
yeah hey that's going to be a senator
soon because we didn't know that he
would be doing hard time for that
exactly now the reason we are showing
this to you is not to say hey trust us
and don't trust anyone else the reason
we're showing this to you is because hey
you think the committee didn't know this
they knew it they had it the entire time
and do you think that other people on
the whether it's Fox News whether you
think they didn't know it long before
Tucker Carlson had some new exclusive
footage what was publicly available
showed you that the vast majority of
people that day not only didn't breach
anything not only didn't Riot they
requested entry and were granted
everyone knew it I I'm telling you this
right now inside baseball everyone in
this industry Left Right knew it very
few people covered it September 28th
20122 so we've gone from 2021 January
2021 now all the way through September
20th 2022 we covered all of this again
which you can go and watch I don't know
if this is still on YouTube I know for
sure it's on mug I think it is yeah I
think I saw this one there at this point
it had become acceptable
on YouTube we did a live A to Z I
believe it was 3 hours on the January
6th committee uh hearings or the release
I don't remember what it was they were
going to do I believe it was going to be
hearing that day which they canceled but
we streamed anyway here you go you
wanted evidence and we'll make sure this
is up with the references at LAD
credit.com the criticism of police
action ranges from questioning their
effectiveness to questioning their
effort one Tennessee Congressman says at
time officers appeared complicit and
that he's never seen a crowd all right
so there's a whole episode you can go
watch it there's a bunch of Clips on
there okay so we have some new footage
though that is true and I say this
because this there's you know letter of
the law Spirit of the law the spirit of
what we've known hasn't changed not at
all the letter of the law here of what
we know has changed a little bit
um and and I think that the primary
change that I see is um uh Capitol
Police being either accompli or an
accessory to uh treason if that's the
case if that's the charge because when
you release someone's restraints and you
fist bump them and send them into the
capital if you either you knew that it
was a riot and an Insurrection or and by
the way it's also kind of hard because
Donald Trump was still president at this
point I guess to an Insurrection against
himself I know it was to stop an
election but this is pretty silly yeah
one writer this is the clip like this
police officer Capitol Police um is this
person liable at all if people are being
arrested for treason and he says yeah
great go on in and commit
treason and there's no audio on that
there's no audio some people have said
that they have identified this person we
haven't been able to confirm it
yet yeah some people are trying to say
this may have been an undercover and I I
don't think that's the case here I think
they have identified that this person
did get in some trouble um even though
they fist bump but that that doesn't
like a terrorist do you fist bump a
terrorist as as your you know catching
them yeah you remember when they
uncuffing themb me black Liv matter
protester yeah exactly exactly and you
can also find by the way footage of
people knocking stuff off of desks and
other people picking them up yeah uh
you've already seen the footage that we
have shown you of saying hey let's
remain peaceful of a huge percentage of
people being escorted through being
peaceful Dr Carlson released some more
security footage um here's another one
though and this one is really sad pisses
uh we also have some footage of Matthew
Perna uh this is the guy in this clip in
the red uh the red Maga sweatshirt um
I'll give you the context after because
this is where you have a government
literally uh well literally arresting
lying to their citizens arresting
political dissidents and in this case
unfortunately the guy because he had his
back up against the wall the the the
outcome was tragic so this is Matthew
perner red Maga sweatshirt who was
looking at years in prison on camera
walking calmly through the capital
here's a
clip let him in the red sweater
right there the police officers talking
not paying attention not even really
paying attention so the reason this
matters is because at picture you're
this guy Perna okay you know what you've
done you know how you behaved and then
you're finding out oh they're going
after people they're going so you're
think okay trespassing he turned himself
in to the federal
authorities turned himself in expecting
some kind of leniency very little if any
prison time probably thinking
trespassing didn't misdemeanor charges
charges and then uh the feds demanded or
proposed enhancing the charges to I
believe terrorism to Terror sentencing
and add sentencing no no no so at
sentencing he already pled and they
wanted to add time of course a huge por
so he pled guilty like all right some
for misdemeanor charges deal yeah
misdemeanor is just that can be that can
be a speeding ticket or it can be
trespassing like being kicked out of
JuiceLand in Austin Texas and and his I
think it was his uh which happened to
you I think it was his aunt that I met
at marago at the debut of police state
and she like this this is her nephew
like this is somebody who called her and
talked to her about this that I'm going
to turn myself in and then when he goes
to get before the judge the lawyers call
him and say hey by the way they've
actually they they want to tack on a
terrorism charge to this because they
want to make an example of people who
were walking through the capital those
police officers over there a couple of
them were paying attention two of them
were just sitting there talking to
themselves if you're in fear of your
life if you're in Mortal danger are you
having a conversation or is your head on
a swivel and by the way the way that
they get to this terrorism charge is
that you're trying to obstruct a process
of the government right where they were
trying to confirm a new president nope
that's not what was happening at the
time the only thing they did was shoot
themselves in the foot by doing that
because they actually only postponed and
actually didn't even go back to it
challenging the Slate of electors that's
what was going to happen at that moment
they didn't stop them from confirming
Joe Biden that wasn't even on the table
yet what they did is they stopped
everybody from actually making their
arguments because they finally said
screw it we're done four people have
committed suicide yep and per is one of
them and per is one after finding out
now you have to understand hey you see
what's going on in the news and you know
oh they're going to hang me publicly for
this yeah I am not I am not built for
prison I'm not a criminal 911 part two
everything in the media everything in
the media going they're going to put me
in prison they're probably going to put
me in in general population they're
probably going to put a Target on my
back for sure tell everybody what you
did my life is gone and I turned myself
in after filming my by the way filming
with this camera think he didn't think
he didn't have that footage go look look
this is what happened yeah we've had it
March 2022 committed suicide after um
they demanded at sentencing to increase
the penalties now here's the thing I
know what you'll say but isn't there
some footage of people breaking there's
some footage by the way and it's it's
really tough because these clips have
been released without context where it
looks like fights are breaking out here
fights are breaking out there that
happens but overwhelmingly certainly in
some portions here of the capital where
peaceful for the entirety now often and
this is something that I really do hope
comes from this we can cover this uh on
the side you know the side of of of of
the public of you knowing this
information of providing you with this
information we can't change the laws now
hopefully it applies some pressure to
Republicans and to conservatives to stop
being spineless and do something about
it that's why we've covered this quite a
bit from the moment it happened but
they'll often say well what can be done
now like Pennsylvania St changing its
state constitution uh at this point you
know it's it's a moot point well no no
no it's not hey anyone who is on camera
since all this is released anyone who's
on camera not being
violent they need some restitution for
their jail time or if they're still by
the way facing trial done needs to be
dropped and this is where the government
needs to make it right you have the
ability to right now it's like ah what's
done is done no no what's done is not
done the people who are still alive who
you can see on camera throughout the
entirety of this event I'm not saying if
someone actually did push down a
barricade but I think people can agree
okay trespassing fine shouldn't be in
prison for 20 years for terrorism but
the people who did nothing the peras
assuming that there isn't more footage
that shows him going absolutely nuts
attacking someone's face like he was on
bass Sals doesn't seem like that's very
likely to happen you have the footage
you can see if these people were violent
or not you can see if they were
committing terrorism or not you can see
if they were vandalizing or not every
single one of them goes free and anyone
who lost months or years of their life
yes you owe them a payout it's one of
the few times you will hear me said this
can be done and must be done and anyone
who saw this footage MH there we go
anyone who saw this footage and went
along with it anyway to jail let's be
clear about what this is jailing
sentencing political dissidence they
need to be brought up on charges on
criminal charges they need to be kicked
out and they need to be exposed this is
not just oh tit for tit oh KN for I
lives a whole world blind imagine you're
someone imagine you're someone who's in
who the the Capitol Police invite in you
say everyone be peaceful you take a few
pictures you bring your vintage
Polaroid and then you're looking at
years in a federal penitentiary imagine
that is you right because that's what
these people have had to live through
and there are folks in high positions of
power who are complicit yeah and Adam
kininger and Liz Cheney especially those
two Republicans who tried to give
credibility to the January 6th hearings
the entire hearing we knew was going to
be a circus we didn't know how bad it
was they knew this information they had
those videos to be able to look at you
guys are out of jobs I know Adam and and
and you know Liz thank God the uh the
voters got you or you decided to kind of
Tuck tail and run lucky for you um
everybody else on that out of a job
tomorrow done you've committed a crime
you've jailed political opponents people
who you apparently you can go and occupy
whatever building you want to if you're
Pro Palestine protester or if you're
with a teachers union or if your black
lives matter you can do it then you can
walk through and again you can point out
those crowds and say hey there's some
people there that were violent that we
need to put in jail fantastic let's
apply the same principle to the people
on January 6th you have to let almost
everybody go that you have in custody
right now and you have to say I am sorry
publicly this can never ever happen
again do you understand the slippery
slope that we are on with this it will
only get worse you think Malay down
there that guy coming into office and
you the pendulum swinging that's how you
end up with these authoritarian figures
is because you do stupid stuff like this
long enough and the people get so fed up
they're just so hungry for justice that
they'll do something that maybe isn't in
their own best interest for somebody
promising Justice and it never ends and
you know what one really good thing that
Johnson may have accomplished here is
now Republicans who are running you
might see the next debate being a
mainstream View and by the way freeing
all January 6th political prisoners and
uh and making that right because
everyone's been afraid and I'm telling
you why it's a third rail third rail
because you're banned from Big Tech at
least you were for a very long time now
it shouldn't require people out there
like ourselves and by the way many great
people on Twitter just to be clear
who've also been covering this but it
shouldn't require us and them to do this
when people have access to all of this
footage and they didn't do it at all it
shouldn't require us to do when these
people should have been pardoned within
the month yeah right it shouldn't be
shouldn't be required but I'm willing to
bet that now you'll see everyone being
Bolden I've always believed in freeing
January no they're full of but I'm I'll
take I'll take the win because these
people who are in jail or these people
whose lives have been ruined of course
there needs to be some justice but just
remember when people weren't saying that
not all Republicans were saying that and
if they were saying well we were waiting
for the footage no you all had enough
you all had enough and just based on
what was publicly available and you all
had or most of you had access to this
didn't you didn't you yeah you know what
you didn't have enough of Courage yeah
just because the media was spinning that
January 6 was the worst thing that ever
happened to our country since 911 you
didn't have the balls to stand up and
say wait a minute nobody died that day
other than Ashley babbett all these
other reported deaths yeah you got all
that wrong nobody actually there were
some people that got assaulted we've got
cameras on those guys we can go get
those guys we'll pick them up they
committed a crime we know how to take
care of this everybody else was a
peaceful protester or somebody who went
on a little bit of a tour and if they if
they damaged some stuff yeah fine go go
ahead take care of it I don't know if
it's 60 days if it's six months maybe
that they have to serve for damaging you
know property that can't be replaced
fine but you didn't have the balls to do
that because you didn't want to look
like a Trumper you don't want to look
like you were with the guy who was
claiming the election was stolen you
were a coward Adam Liz and so many
others you're just the two that I know
were on that committee and could have
done something but didn't well stepen
said it right it's an example they're
trying to set an example like a stockade
put them out in front of it this is what
happen to you if you oppose us that's
that's legitimately what they're doing
and this Administration loves prison
they freaking love prison dude you know
how many people the least amount of par
of any not that I care about pardons
that much but when it comes to this kind
of stuff it's a great example the least
amount of Pardons in decades like I'm
talking 6070 years the least amount of
Pardons Donald Trump in four years it
was like 240 250 something like that in
8 years Obama had like 600 700 pardons
in his three years so far Biden nine wow
wow nine pardons he goes to bed too
early those pardons come in at nine him
him and all the laws that he made as a
senator in the '90s and Camala Harris
with all the people that she put behind
fre labor yeah both of those people this
Administration completely loves prison
and it's the left's biggest weapon right
now that's why they got Trump on uh
getting hearings right after the
primaries are ending uh they got all
these January 6 they're setting an
example of what like that's what a
Banana Republic does that's what that's
what Argentina should be doing you know
and that's what Biden's doing they're
like put these people for walking around
the capital in prison for years yeah
it's a very good point whereas no it's a
great Point Josh show Josh you love him
than service a great
and when you compare it too the fact
that hey the people on the right are
going on a second a second violent
criminals should be in prison and the
left says no no no they they can get out
with it they don't even need any cash
just just let them back out no bail let
them go yeah just yeah no promise you'll
be good but this guy with a with a flip
phone filming himself in the capital
where he was escorted by Capital police
life in rape me prison that's what we're
actually dealing with here that is evil
that is absolutely evil and you talk
about setting an example guess what big
Tech's already done it most
conservatives play along that's the
truth that's the truth you're now
dealing with this right in government
but from the the sphere of of public
perception big Tech said can't talk
about elections can't question vaccines
can't talk about January 6th period and
most people said fine thank you for
supporting us on Rumble and mug Club I
guess Tim we have finegan maybe he's
been calling we got still calling okay
one more time
let's
okay finnean how are you hi Stephen I
found one what come here little guy
[Music]
oh
he'll he'll rub some dirt on it uh again
Crowder shop going to the holidays 20%
off the hoodies using the promo code
Patriot 20 and uh right now we are every
single dollar 10 entries for a 2024 Ford
Raptor bab and $10,000 cash don't say
baby I hate it when you say baby because
it makes you sound like you want to be a
black athlete but you're
not,
cash 2024 for Raptor at Crowder shop
that some like yeah baby it's like it's
like they feel like people are like oh
yes that's a white thing to say mhm baby
there are babies that are white you
know all right we're going to play hate
symbol or not if you're watching on
Rumble just click this right now you get
to join mug club and watch this there's
no way even we could run it on Rumble
but we're not this is hate symbol or not
is a love letter to mug Club thank you
Rumble YouTube I don't I know there's
very little on YouTube today it's pretty
much all been dump button so you know
what you already you knew this was
coming piss
off
yeah